ah
good morning everybody
what a delightful morning sometimes you
just wake up you praise the sun you make
yourself a nice cup of coffee and
fromsoft drops 15 minutes of ellen ring
gameplay
this is very exciting
and i also suspect though even though it
was announced to be 15 minutes of
gameplay this is gonna be longer than
that based on
the actual length of this video on
gamespot's channel here so not only is
it 15 minutes
it's more than 15 minutes when it comes
to what i would like to see from this um
i'm not super picky what got me in the
original reveal was character design
which naturally they've always been
incredibly good at especially enemy
design
i have obviously read up on a lot of
stuff about how the open world works and
all of that and i'd love to see a little
bit more detail where that's concerned
but um the truth is i already know that
i'm getting this game there's nothing i
require here
i
feel like i wasn't super impressed with
it graphically
um when we first saw it so i'm gonna be
paying attention to that as well
but generally just happy to be here man
having a good time let's
do it
five four
three
two
one
hello everyone
thank you for taking the time to join us
today no worries dude in this video
we'll show some footage of our new
action rpg elden ring
we hope it helps to convey a little of
this title's mood and gameplay
let's go let's go let's go let's do it
so far it's not conveying much okay i
take it back
eldon ring is set here in the lands
between
oh it's so pretty
this is a sight of grace
acting as a place of rest for the play
occasionally grace will manifest rays of
guiding light oh my god it's so pretty
look at these ghost tsushima breath of
the wild vibes we're free to choose
whether to follow this guy who knew from
you how to make things colorful sakura's
colorful
the stream quality is not great i will
mention um it's it's not looking great
on stream even though i am running it in
1080 um probably better to watch
um
a hd version later
oh my gosh
i wonder how scripted that was
that's exciting
is he always gonna show up there
i don't think that that was scripted
i don't think that was
linear oh that's neat
do love how much you can do from
horseback that's awesome
big chunky boy
oh i thought it looked like it was
coming from his eye for a second it's
not
also noticing there's no hud here
i'm assuming the game will have a hud
but if you can turn it off i am all for
trying that
be real tricky in a from stuff game
though i think
yes
hello hello
please anyone
oh my stars i'm so i'm sorry who's
talking to me right now i am
and as you can see i'm stuck here
okay
can you help me out of this i'd love to
put those doubts to rest i'll be just
fine
i'm very well trained
give it your all i say this is such an
interesting thing to choose to show
in this presentation
he's gonna fight back charlie's gonna
fight back
that part's not gonna take that look at
him sassy little pot
you've upset him
ah
well played good sir well oh he is the
pot i thought it was a man inside the
pot it is the pot
incredible 10 out of 10 game of the year
amazing
great love it i love it
hmm i'm liking the looks of some of
these getups as well
that's also pretty solid draw distance
i was curious
useful when exploring the world and is
populated by acquiring map fragments
that make sense
also breath of the wild lee
we can use markers to customize the map
such as setting reminders for the
location of crafting materials or
dangerous enemies
it looks great i really like the map
that's neat
oh also good
maybe you can play it without a hud in a
lot of ways
oh
spirit springs can be used while on
horseback to launch high into the air
this allows for stress-free traversal of
areas with a great deal of vertical and
this is a lot of verticality
i mean security did too and and they
manage the traversal for that very well
i wonder if it's dynamic weather as well
i'm not surprised this game took this
long to make
yeah i mean the map must be huge for
them to introduce a mount
listen you don't understand how hard it
is
to make creatures with four legs
functional okay
it's real hard that is a difficult thing
to do in game development
so
the mount has to be there because the
map is carrying treasure is huge an
opportunity too good to pass up
otherwise you just wouldn't put the
effort we'll prepare for combat
inventory looks looks
familiar
[Applause]
enemy stance can be broken with heavy
a variety of unique attacks can also be
interchanged between weapons
nice
definitely in terms of the um
speed the combat is
more dark souls than bloodborne or
sakura by the looks of it
in more perilous situations we can
summon spirits to assist us in battle
the vibes are definitely lord of the
rings as well which is kind of like very
gratefully in tight works with the
georgia armenian inspiration
that doesn't surprise me
i'm liking the amount of color
online multiplayer can also be enjoyed
with players from other worlds from
cooperative to pvp and invasions cool
i wonder how much co-op there can be
like is it is there a party system is it
random
that's interesting
oh i should also just realize he's jewel
wielding
what is that a spear and a staff
deadly creatures stalk this forest so
we'll use stealth to avoid detection
oh my god i'm also getting like dragons
dogma vibes which is like one of my
favorite rpgs ever
though i will say
as much as i'm liking the color i like
the design obviously which matters more
to me than graphics anyway yeah i still
feel like demon souls
um
outshines this graphically but it's not
really something i care about
it's always nice to have
that's come across a boss guarding this
area um nice to have take it on with the
help of our car
but i never feel like it's straight
oh he's cool
i wonder how this this co-op system
works i'm very nice
spell casting looks super neat too whoa
that's sick
oh
that's so cool
oh my gosh
dude
what what
oh god she summoned the old dragon
not a whole time just his head but still
that was sick
oh my god loving these rays
we haven't seen any ui at all like there
was no
door push for that which makes me think
there is a hud
catacombs caves
and other dungeons can be found while
out exploring the world
my mind
these dungeons each hold their own
secrets from hidden treasures to fears
some bosses also is he australian
what is your accent sir
are you one of me
i'm clear
this stream quality is definitely not
helping the game that's such a shame
yeah i'll go back and watch some pretty
hd stuff
oh very nice
loving the range of lighting
it definitely looks really atmospheric
which like sakura
no they're all their games are good at
atmosphere
they all have
fantastic examples
hello
greetings greetings traveller
from beyond the fog they've always got
to have a cute moody chick
every time
she's gonna be cute she's gonna be cute
she's gonna be cute
she's cute confirmed cute
i
offer you an accord
we've reached stormvale castle a
large-scale dungeon which connects
seamlessly with the surroundings
large-scale dungeons
that's not a great sign
got typos in your captions huh
you're tarnished aren't you are you dead
i would advise against taking the main
gate into the castle
it's tightly guarded by hardened old
hands
oh
try the opening right here
the
i just love their character design it's
so
you don't cool to trust me
well
if you must go through the gates i'll
signal them to open
but of course i'd advise against it
no i'm just really curious about what's
gonna happen
old hands huh
oh my
give us right
the main route seems risky so we'll try
entering through a back way
i'm really liking the weather effects
i'm very curious this is very demon
souls um very curious
about if they're dynamic
i don't know if they said that anyway
yet
so
extra care should be taken when moving
through dungeons as visibility and
terrain differ from when in the open
make sense we hope players enjoy getting
a feel for the different types of areas
cool that you can do with the suitable
strategies
i mean there's more density in here i
feel like
who is that man
what is he up to oh my god
definitely i would say a lot of these
environments feel familiar
which
in the case of a lot of other developers
i would consider a criticism but
i think that the
open world structure is going to change
the feel of this
very significantly i i'm not actually
concerned in this case
i mean obviously they're running on the
same engine too so there's only so much
they can do dungeons are complex and
multi-layered meaning they can be
tackled from a number of routes very
cool so yeah i do think this this more
open world approach the verticality i'm
really sold on um is going to make it
feel very fresh
is that the sorting hat nice to meet you
the pleasure's mine
roger is the name
a sorcerer as
you might have guessed i didn't i'm
looking for a little something
here in the castle
when i'm not hot-footing it from the
troops that is but enough about me
what are you doing here in stormdale
castle
this place is
they sacrifice our kind
for grafting not exactly a place i'd
stroll into without a purpose in mine
everyone seems very talkative which i
like
what was that oh it's just somebody with
a with a
hood and a
helmet that makes sense
is it gonna be
so no fall damage
it's not a sakura situation where you
have the um
i don't know what it's called
in this next boss fight we challenge one
of the demigods
ruler of stormville godric the golden
what up godric let me see you let me get
at it
i would like to see it
lend me thy strength o kindred
deliver me unto
greater heights
you need a manicure bruh
it's not looking good
you sure do
play
again very lord of the rings vibes
[Music]
and this is a big arena
uh it's actually it's
more
oh boy oh bitrate
[Music]
i don't know how you collect the like
summons too
is that a permanent
permanent environmental change of wonder
i don't know
i don't think so i think that was just
an effect
i'm loving all this dragon content
dragon souls they call it
stream quality really hurting hurting
this one there
oh my god
oh my god that's so cool
thank you for watching anytime any this
was just a brief introduction to elden
rings fundamentals
but more details will be revealed at a
later date
there's not long to go now before
release
in the meantime we greatly appreciate
your continued support it might be
british i'm not sure the tarnished will
soon return
oh yeah dude
i will
um
someone must extinguish
style i'm a huge fan because i feel like
i expressed all my photos
i think it looks cool i'm totally gonna
play it like there's no there's no doubt
um i like the vibe a lot
i'm very interested in how the world
makes everything feel to be born
[Music]
that's so cool very good very good
yeah available i don't know what comes
with the statue
the helmet
i don't pre-order stuff
um but i will be purchasing that helmet
if it comes separately or on ebay at
some point thank you very much
uh yeah we'd love to hear what everybody
thinks um looks great to me definitely
looks reminiscent of their other games
definitely think the verticality is
impressive i guess i'll just let this
continue to play in because something
else shows up
um
the open world thing i i think is going
to make it fairly different i'm super
interested in how the co-op
works um
how much of that you can do because that
could be awesome if you can actually
play like the whole game call up with a
friend or something i don't know they
might have spoken about that somewhere
um
like is there cross play etc um
super into it yeah uh clearly running on
an older engine that is noticeable to me
not something i care about a whole lot
in general i'm
always care more about the design the
art style and the design of a video game
world
and this does look like it has a really
consistent very pretty very
aesthetically pleasing design they're so
good at character design their
environments are also generally
incredible um
ah this is like one of those games
where
um i like get annoyed watching footage
because i can't play it yet so
that's where we're at we'd love to know
what you guys think let me know i will
see you guys next time